can ask you some weird thing about
friendship of course because you
mentioned
um sam he's mr harris to you um
didn't that bother you how he went after
joe uh what did he do just like oh in
case you guys have brain damage from
watching rogan's last episode like watch
here's the answer and it's all like digs
like that yeah yeah i didn't like that i
didn't like that either uh i think sam
doesn't like it either about himself
okay
uh he regrets those things because it's
very easy to say from his perspective
look
this isn't the full side rogan didn't
show you the full side story here's the
other side of the story please watch
this and be informed that's a very
reasonable thing to say
yeah i don't quite understand so they
they do this about each other now
um i'll put three people on the table
which is joe rogan sam harrison and
brett weinstein
and they have a way of talking like the
other person is creating a lot of harm
like
publicly would say things like that and
i understand there's emotion in it
but like these are human beings
that are friends of yours but i'll go
the other way let's suppose it is true
that joe is doing a lot of harm
spreading misinformation
being sarcastic isn't going to be
persuasive
whereas if you're like he's wrong
here's the facts or hears or be informed
that to me but then i'm not sam harris
i'm not he's got a bigger audience to me
so maybe he's the one who's right i'm
wrong no he's well he's just human
okay well i can't relate
well have you seen your twitter lately i
mean you're twi you get very you have a
lot of fun on twitter i feel like
twitter let's
i've never done that with someone i'm
friends with i never would
okay let's put that on record it trolls
me because if there's an issue with you
i'm getting you on the phone yeah
good i mean because then i'm not backing
you into a corner publicly it doesn't
make any sense strategically yeah and
actually um
brett weinstein
um tweeted something sort of criticizing
something i did already forgot what but
he texted me first saying like is it
okay if i tweet this yeah and i i said
yep
like i was excited yeah but i think
there's some level of just
be compassionate privately and be
compassionate publicly like well civil
civil yeah i i i for some reason i don't
like the word civility because it
it's like polite i do like it it's uh
it'd be cordial is that better no what i
mean is like
it seems funny to you it seems phony
like you should radiate love in whatever
way so even if you're rough with the
other person you should still
show like respect and love for that
person and that that gets back to the
russian rooms where they're yelling at
each other but there's still love
underneath it i mean uh the question i
want to ask for you
is uh
i think you and i have a different view
on some things okay we have a different
approach to things but just on the
surface level but also a different view
on some things like i have a lot of hope
for institutions i i
have so maybe it's a gut instinct like
your gut instinct is like
centers of power are like burn them down
first and then let's figure it out or
maybe that's a funny rough way of saying
that's about right and then for me it's
like no let's
understand the institution and slowly
um
revolutions from within versus
revolutions from the doubt and
um
but like we can have those disagreements
and there may be times when those
disagreements will be i could see in the
future i could see i'll be attacked
by my friend michael malus which i very
look forward to it will not attack but
you know what i mean on the surface
level in the idea space anyway i guess
you're shaking your head now you won't i
guess i'm
maybe this also goes to sam harrison
uh joe rogan i would love to be able to
disagree
disagree in big ways unimportant things
and still be close friends
and i don't understand why those are
should be contradictions yeah and that's
the tension that's been the most
heartbreaking thing to me about
sam and brett and joe
what in the case of brett it's me i
don't know brett so i'm just like
looking as a somebody who just enjoys
having these voices out there and it
seems like coverage is brought out the
worst than some
many folks
and it just feels like it's so sad to me
to see their friendship
somewhat deteriorating or maybe i'm just
being an um no it seems clear that's
deteriorated enormously
sad but that's the case yeah so my like
i've had people come at me because i'm
friends with you
and they were like oh lex authored some
paper about masks i don't even know what
the hell they're referring to i don't
care um i always say
and mean
i don't care
whether someone agrees with me i care
how they treat me
and it goes the other way because i'll
have a lot of people on twitter who are
like oh i'm on your team and blah blah
i'm like i don't know you you're not my
team
and just because you haven't agree with
me it's of no value to me like i don't
know you and i'm interested in knowing
you
many of my friends i don't know their
politics there i don't care like i care
how we hang out we have a good time we
watch dumb movies watch youtube go to
the store whatever um i don't know your
politics are i don't care what your
politics are um
chris williamson who you know he's just
here he's going to be moving to austin
i only learned what his politics are in
the last we've been we chat like almost
every day because he took the world's
smallest political quiz
and he figured out what his answers were
i had no idea he's communist he said
well obviously yeah yeah marxist
yeah let's be honest
um
so like stuff like that like it never
and people
uh i think because politics is often so
tribal especially now
uh
they'll be like oh i could never be
friends with someone who voted for x
really what if they're like grandma
worked in that campaign what if you know
it's this
you can't think of one steel man
argument why this would happen but if
they just want to spite their boss
um so i i don't like that approach at
all it makes no sense to me
um
we could still have debates i mean
like i would still like to have those
conversations and still have
disagreements
like uh
i i disagree with joe and kovid a lot on
a bunch of different things very kind of
but it's never like
it's not tense at all it's it's it's
just
it's uh it doesn't have the arrogance
that seems
a lot of kobe conversation seems to have
like
uh talking down to people from both
directions yeah yeah it's um so i would
love to have those because i love the
debate that i love debates it takes a
lot to get me triggered and when the
babylon b were interviewing elon
and he had this thing he goes well i
don't know anyone who wants to you know
abolish the fda and the faa and i'm
standing there
and i'm shaking and the guys look at me
and they're like oh we actually have an
anarchist here and the example he used
was
you know look if you're playing football
you're going to have a referee there and
you want the referee you know you don't
but the referee started playing the game
is
such a good thing and i'm sitting there
like the referee doesn't work for the
state yeah the referee is a private
individual working for this organization
yeah and there's no reason at all that
food quality which is something
crucially important
has to be or can only be delivered
through the state in a government
monopoly
that's actually really interesting just
to link on that
just just just a little bit with the
vaccine and stuff like that with the
antiviral drugs the fda say like are you
comfortable like who should be the
referee
right
like do you have an idea like what's the
best referee for the vex it's it's just
the market
just like people decide this is tricky
because the thing the thing that
i have not been following covert as
closely as joe and sam as mr harris
excuse me and mr musk
the point is
when anything like this is developing
there's going to be a lot of
misinformation out there even from the
scientists because it's a dynamic
process they don't know what they're
dealing with a lot of it has to be
speculative they don't know long-term
effects because it hasn't been around
for a long time
so
i think it is very
um
dangerous
when you know when joe was mocked for
taking a laundry list of things under
his doctor's advice
and they kind of latched on to the
ivermectin and then they specifically
said it was horse paste although it's
veterinary medicines why didn't they dog
paste or cap based
it's like well he's not dead
so and he's also taking drugs
which are used in other circumstances
the very least maybe they're pointless
but
if the drug is being allowed for
pharmaceutical reasons the odds are
quite low that they're going to have
deleterious side effects
in general so
i think this kind of insistence
that there has to be one
a officially approved
outcome
that we're all doing that is kind of
dangerous thinking in general
you